- [Kelly] So wait, I hear that
y'all know each other, right?
- Well, first of all, that
was awkward, me acting.
And I got one of the
greatest, one of the guys
I've always looked up to.
- [Kelly] That wasn't awkward!
- Did you see me?
I was like, "Yes! That was amazing!"
(audience applause)
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's
exactly what he did actually.
No, it was great.
And what a great scene too,
that a lot of kids relate to
and parents will relate to as well, sadly.
But y'all know each other?
- Yeah, yeah.
I got invited to do a little
workout with Laird Hamilton.
You know Laird Hamilton?
He's the hundred foot big wave-
- [Kelly] Totally.
- crazy surfer.
And he says, "Hey".
I saw him on the beach one time.
And he goes, "Hey, come up
and come work out with me".
So I go to his house up in Malibu-
- [Kelly} Do dudes do that a lot?
Y'all are just like, "Hey,
come work out with me?"
- That's all we do actually.
- Yeah that's it.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- That's what we do.
- So glad I'm a woman right now.
(laughs)
- But he's got this pool
and it's custom made for these workouts,
these underwater workouts with weights.
And so I go up there
and I jump in the pool
and I see him coming
out and he's shredded,
and I'm like, "Well, this is
a pretty cool little workout."
And I start to do the workout
and you're under water.
- You're panicking.
- And you can't breathe.
- Oh, you're not doing it
and your head's above water.
You're underwater.
- No, you're under water.
And Laird, he serves a hundred foot wave.
He's crazy.
He's like, '"Hey, go do a
workout, get underneath the water.
Then you, then you're gonna
go to the ice cold tub,
which just filled with ice."
- Those are good for you.
- And then from there,
you go to 180 degree sauna
and you do a bike for 20 minutes.
And I'm like, I almost die.
- What does your heart
do during this? Yeah.
- But he does it all
the time, this workout.
- Yeah. But what's great
is that you look at him
and you go, "No, this guy's gonna show up
and he is gonna control the whole pool."
And he got there and he started crying.
And-
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- One of the worst things
I ever did in my life.
- Really?
- I was like-
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I slept like a baby.
- You did great. You did great.
- Oh my God, this reminds me.
It was one time, my friends on a vacation,
they're like, "We're gonna
go on this beautiful hike."
And I was like, "Hell yeah, let's do it."
It was like fat camp from hell.
(man and audience laughs)
- My stomach got upset.
I was like, 'oh my god";
I was like, it was the
worst experience of my life.
- [Both Men] Yeah.
- And that's why I don't work out.
So we're celebrating
the eighties all week.
So do you have a favorite eighties memory?
- Well, you know, that's
when I grew up, obviously.
I mean, I was born 1976
so the eighties were my decade
to make who I am right now.
And so I spent it watching movies.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And obviously I know you
guys talked about Goonies.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- But I loved Weird Science.
- [Kelly] Weird Science, Kelly Lebrock.
- Kelly Lebrock.
- I was like, "Were we
supposed to come out
looking like that?"
- Yeah.
- She's beautiful.
- Eddie Murphy Coming to America.
- My God. So great.
- All those movies.
Commando.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I loved The First Blood
with Sylvester Stallone.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The Rocky movies.
I loved eighties.
- I loved all those too.
Yeah.
- And this is back, most
the kids that like today.
I have four kids.
And they watch a movie like one time
and then they'll never watch it again.
I mean hardly.
Unless it's like, Let
it Go, or one of those.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You're
talking about Frozen.
- Don't get me started.
- It wasn't let it go.
(Kelly laughs)
- Let it go.
- That's like calling Encanto
"We Don't Talk About Bruno".
- Same thing.
- That's amazing.
- But back in the eighties, we
we watched the movies over
and over and over again.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I've seen Goonies 300 times.
Not kidding.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, Labyrinth, David Bowie.
- David Bowie. - Whatever.
- Top gun. - Top Gun.
- I've seen that 87 times.
- Yep.
- All those movies.
By the way, fun fact.
Chunk. - Mm hmm -
Goonies. - Mm hmm.
- Do you know where I'm going with this?
- No. - Do you have any idea?
- [Kelly] I don't either.
- The fact that he's a lawyer now.
- He is a lawyer now.
But I went to Berkeley.
I played football and basketball there.
He was the yell leader on
the cheerleading squad.
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- [Josh] What?
- So during the game.
- [Josh] Oh man.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- No.
- I remember one time we're in the middle
of a game and both teams
were playing the game
standing on the side and the
defense was on the field.
And all of a sudden we
hear the crowd going crazy.
I'm like, there's nothing
happening on the field.
And I turn around and I see
Chunk doing the truffle shuffle.
He's got his shirt up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Josh] No, really?
(audience laughs)
- True story.
No true story.
My brother, who's a decade older than me,
would make me do that to
get into our apartment.
- Come on!
- He'd on the balcony and I'd have to do.
I was chunky.
And he'd make me do the
truffle shuffle to get in.
I think it made me funny in the end.
- Who's go at the talk show now?
- Yeah, who's talking now in therapy?
OK, so your new show is
called Long Slow Exhale.
- Yep.
- That is an interesting name.
So explain what it's about.
- So it's about a collegiate
female basketball team
that just won the national championship.
And then off of that, scandal rocks
the whole university and sex scandal.
There is the first couple
episodes came out already.
There's a murder.
And then I play a father within the story.
I'm the story within the story.
And that's where I really
loved being able to do this
because kind of tapping into
that, you know, being parents
and working with my daughter,
wanting the best from her
but she doesn't know why.
I have a little secret.
You're gonna have to watch the show
but there's a reason
why I'm so hard on her.
And why I'm trying to
get the best out of her.
- I was gonna say you kind
of seem like a hardass.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I have to be.
- My mom was and I turned out fine.
- Look at you.
- Once again in therapy,
but everything's fine.
Just kidding, I love you Mommy.
We need another commercial
break everybody.
Tony's new show, Long Slow
Exhale is on Spectrum now.
Be sure to check it out.